MARC COHEN: OK.
Why don't we get started?
Welcome.
This is a session about
Google Cloud Storage.
We're going to try to
make this a regular
Office Hours session.
And so the idea here will be
to share a quick tech talk,
which I'll present in a moment,
and to give you guys a
chance to ask any questions
you might have.
We've got a Moderator, a list of
questions that people have
already submitted things to.
And we also have a Chat
window in the Hangout.
So if you see that little Chat
button, you can open that up
to submit your questions
as well.
I want to introduce
Ville Aikas.
He's on the Hangout with us.
Ville is the technical lead
for the Cloud Storage
Engineering Team.
VILLE AIKAS: Hi, guys.
Welcome.
MARC COHEN: If you have
questions and you want to send
them in the Chat window, Ville
will be taking a look at that
as well as helping me out with
any live questions you have.
OK.
Let's start.
Let me share my screen here.
OK, is everyone seeing the slide
that I have here that
says Google Cloud Storage,
a title slide?
OK.
So as I said, the agenda is 30
minutes on quick tech talk and
then Q&A. The tech talk topic
will be CNAME Redirection and
Website Configuration.
Those are really two different
sub-features, but they go
together nicely.
So we'll try to cover
both of those.
Start with a little bit
of terminology.
So Google Cloud Storage is
Google's way of making our
internal storage infrastructure
available for
application developers.
A lot of people often confuse it
with Google Drive, which is
more of a consumer cloud
storage capability.
So there are two different
products.
And we're not talking about
Google Drive today.
We're talking about Google
Cloud Storage.
Within Google Cloud Storage,
we divide up the world into
buckets and objects.
So buckets are object
containers.
They're essentially somewhat
like folders or directories,
if you're familiar with
those concepts.
And objects themselves
are the contents.
So they're kind of like files
in a file system.
And the URLs shown here are
depicting the syntax you would
use to specify a bucket
or an object,
respectively, using a URL.
And one of the nice features of
Cloud Storage is that when
you create these resources,
you can programmatically
access them.
But you can also access them
with HTTP by pasting a URL
into your standard
web browser.
And this is giving an example
of what the URLs would look
like for a bucket
and an object.
I have this notion
of directories.
And it's a little bit tricky
because, technically, the
storage subsystem is a two-level
level hierarchy,
simply buckets and objects.
And the notion of a
directory in this
context is purely abstract.
So there's not an actual formal
directory or folder in
the system.
But rather, if you created an
object with a slash-delimited
name, sometimes we think of
those intermediate nodes in
the name as directories because
they look like file
system directories.
They're technically not.
So if you look at the second
URL there, the
storage.googleap
is.com/bucket/directory/object,
that's actually the name of
an object whose name is
directory/object.
That compound name is the
object's name, and then bucket
is the container.
Next we have the CNAMEs.
And so CNAMEs are a
special type of
record in the DNS system.
And CNAMEs are used to alias
one name to another.
So when you do DNS lookup, if
the name you're looking up has
an alias, you'll get back,
depending on the
configuration, the
CNAME alias.
And then you can resolve the
alias name to find the actual
destination.
So it's basically a
way of redirecting
from one name to another.
We'll talk about why you might
want to do that in a second.
The last definition here
is static websites.
And these are websites
that have no
active server-side logic.
So if you're used to thinking
about PHP or Python or Pearl
or Java probably more likely
doing the active runtime logic
of templatizing or doing
database lookups, or something
active when you're fetching
pages, static web pages are
those that don't actually do
anything on the server side.
It doesn't mean that they're
totally static in the sense
that they're not really
doing anything.
A lot of websites can do
client-side dynamic things
that are quite elaborate.
And we'll see an example of a
page like that or really a
site like that in
a few minutes.
So CNAME redirection, why would
you want to do that?
It enables you to associate
names with your storage
objects that are more natural
and more meaningful.
So by default, you can create
resources in Google Cloud
Storage which are accessible
through this URI--
storage.googleapis.com.
And so you can qualify your
bucket to be meaningful to
your particular company or your
application, or however
you want to name the bucket.
But at the end of the day, you
would end up giving out these
URLs that are vectored off of
storage.googleapis.com.
And you might prefer to have
the resources be named with
your own company's
domain name.
And that's exactly what CNAME
redirection lets you do,
create your URL like the first
example there, like
my.company.com, slash, whatever
resource, instead of
having to use the Google API's
dot-com domain as the
root of your path.
And by the way, if anybody has
questions as we're going
along, feel free to
just jump in.
And we have a small enough
group here that
that should be fine.
In a nutshell, the procedure
for using this CNAME
redirection feature is to obtain
a domain name if you
don't already have one.
You need to go through a few
steps to verify ownership of
the domain.
So that basically entails
proving to Google that you
actually have the rights
to that domain name.
And the reason there is,
obviously we can't let anybody
have ownership of buckets in
the name space of somebody
else who might actually
be the rightful owner
of that domain name.
And so there are
three different
ways you can do that.
I won't go into the
details here.
But the easiest one entails
serving a file with a
particular value on the website
associated with the
domain name in question.
And that proves that you
actually have ownership,
because you were able to save
that file at that URL.
And then after you verify
ownership of the domain name,
you would configure the DNS
directory system to actually
have the CNAME record, which is
aliasing your domain name
to this pattern, this
c.storage.googleapis.com.
So that's a special URL that
gets routed into Google that's
specifically there to do the
right thing with mapping the
CNAME into the resource
relative to
Google's name space.
With that, users can then use
your company names, like I
mentioned earlier.
And you can advertise your
resources in a way that's
really natural.
It looks like it's in your own
website rather than in
Google's website space.
One caveat to know about is
that CNAME redirection is
supported only for
HTTP, not HTTPS.
So question?
We're up to 16 viewers,
which is great.
I'll just repeat.
If anybody on the call wants to
add questions, feel free to
in the Chat window.
And also if you're live
streaming via
YouTube, there is a--
actually, one thing I didn't
mention, if you look at the
very first slide, these slides
are available right now
through
tinyurl..com/gcs-office-hours.
So if you'd like to follow along
with the slides, you're
welcome to.
And we also have a moderated
question queue,
which is down here.
So the page that you came in on,
either to livestream the
video or to join the Hangout,
if you scroll down to the
bottom, you'll see a moderated
set of questions.
So feel free to post
there as well.
And we'll try to get to as many
of those as we can in the
second half of the talk.
Any questions before
I pick up again?
Let's zip ahead here.
So we covered CNAME
redirection.
And I'm actually going
to show you an
example of that shortly.
But now I would like to switch
gears to website
configuration.
And so what website
configuration?
It's basically a feature that
we've added recently that
gives you the ability to serve
an entire website directly
from Google Cloud Storage.
Why is this useful?
Why would you care about this?
There are few reasons.
One is that dynamic logic
in web applications is
increasingly client-side
based.
And so you can do some very
cool things purely in
JavaScript without having to
do much work at all, having
essentially a static server-side
component.
And in fact, it's a nice pattern
for building your web
applications because it scales
very well, because you're
harnessing the computing
capacity of the clients rather
than having to multiply capacity
to serve a number of
users on a small
set of servers.
Some websites just happen
to be very simple.
If you're an App Engine user,
for example, and you've ever
wanted to build a small app
that just serves up some
relatively simple content and
you wondered why do I have to
build a whole application
just to do this?
Well, you don't have
to anymore.
And this feature I'm talking
about is a perfect alternative
for that type of task.
It's ideal for caching of
read-mostly websites.
So if you have something like a
blog where you might post an
article once a day or something
once a few hours or
something on that order,
this is a great way
to cache that site.
So anytime the content changes,
you can post a copy
of the entire blog or the
website or just the changed
components to Google Cloud
Storage and then serve that up
really nicely without having--
I'll explain what I mean by why
it's great to serve that
up so well in the next bullet.
But before I move to that, I
just want to mention that
there are WordPress plug-ins out
there which make this sort
of thing easy for caching
blogs to offsite readers
basically or offsite
storage servers.
And if anyone out there is
interested, I think this would
be a great project for building
an app on top of
Google Cloud Storage to extend
one of those plug-ins or to
create a new one to push
WordPress content over to
Google Cloud Storage.
And the reason why it's useful
to push your content, your
blog content-- you might be
wondering, if I have a blog
and it's serving up content
every day, why do I care?
Why would I want to
push cached copies
of it on Cloud Storage?
And the reason is scalability.
If your blog is successful, if
you ever get slash-dotted or
post something that attracts a
lot of interest, your usage is
going to spike, probably
very suddenly.
And what typically happens is
people who deploy blogs on
relatively small footprints
where you might be paying per
server or per virtual server,
you can't tolerate the spike
in traffic sometimes.
And that's really bad because
when you most need the
capacity, at the point in time
when your blog is suddenly the
most popular it's ever been, it
falls over and it fails to
respond appropriately.
And so it's really nice to be
able to just dynamically
absorb all that traffic and
perform equally well under
very high load as well
as the norm.
And that's what you get with
deploying not just a blog but
any static website on Google
Cloud Storage.
You get virtually unlimited
scaling.
You get incredibly
high performance.
And you get a global footprint
where people can read this
content, access your website all
around the world thanks to
the fact that Google Cloud
Storage is deployed on
Google's global worldwide
network.
So you get all these benefits
that you wouldn't have if you
were in a more constrained
web-hosting or blog-serving
type environment.
So a few words--
is there a question?
A little bit about how website
configuration works.
So we've added two new
metadata properties.
And these are applied on
a per-bucket basis.
So you'll typically define a
bucket, and that will be the
root of your website.
And you'll associate with that
bucket a MainPageSuffix and a
NotFoundPage property.
When you've set those, if
someone does a GET Object
either on the bucket itself or
on what we refer to as a
directory, kind of a virtual
directory underneath that
bucket, we will look for an
object underneath that path
with the specified name that
you've set for MainPageSuffix.
And if it exists, we'll deliver
it up automatically.
So the nice thing about this is
you don't have to actually
distribute your URLs with the
form pathname/index.html or
whatever the name is of the file
that contains the home
page or the default page.
It works kind of naturally if
you're used to Apache or any
other popular web server.
You get a default page that gets
served up automatically.
And you can specify which
page it is as well.
So it doesn't have
to be index.html.
It can be any name you like.
And equivalently, you can do
the same thing with this
NotFoundPage metadata.
And that, as you might guess
from the name, is giving you
the ability to serve up a page
that is providing a response
whenever a resource that's
requested is not available,
essentially the 404
capability.
Let's see.
The other thing is this metadata
defines names.
But it doesn't define content.
So you actually upload objects
into those names in order to
have the content of the
page delivered.
And I'll show you how that
all works in a second.
So the procedure for doing this
is to upload content into
a bucket, you have to make
sure the ACLs are set
according to your intended
access permission.
So if you're, for example,
doing, again, a blog where you
want everybody in the world to
be able to access the content,
you'd set the public read
access control so that
everybody can see your
content anywhere.
You want to create and upload
default pages for the bucket
and optionally for any
directories you care about And
then you may, in addition, want
to create a custom 404
page as well if you're
interested in that.
And then you'll set
one or both of the
following metadata values.
And I already covered that.
You can do that either
via the XML API or
with the gsutil tool.
The gsutil tool makes
it very easy.
And I'll show how that
works, in a minute.
This is a pictorial diagram of
the logic that's happening
behind the scenes when you
actually submit a request.
And I'm not going to
walk through this.
We can if people want to
drill down into it.
But this picture comes from
our online documentation.
And you'll see at the end of the
talk a list of resources
you can use to read more
about this future.
But I'd like to jump into the
demo because I think it's a
little bit easier to explain
something interactively.
So let me switch over here.
Are you guys still
seeing my screen?
You should be seeing
a shell window.
AUDIENCE: It's delayed.
MARC COHEN: OK.
So as part of this talk, I
created a new domain name.
And it's called "Cloud and
Clear." I thought that would
be a cute name for a
blog at some point.
So I just created this domain
name a couple of days ago.
And as you can see, I was able
to create a bucket for it.
So I named the bucket after
the domain name.
It's cloud-and-clear.com.
I'm using gsutil.
For those who haven't seen it,
it's a command-line utility
that lets me do all
sorts of things.
If I do Help, it'll show you
all the kinds of things you
can do here.
But it makes it very easy to
upload, download, list,
modify, set access permissions,
et cetera, on my
Google Cloud Storage
resources.
So what I've done is I have
created this bucket.
And in order to create this
bucket, I had to prove that I
owned the domain name.
So I went through the procedure
doing that, and
we'll do minus b here.
There's information
about the bucket.
So I went through the process of
registering a domain name,
proving that I owned it.
And then I created
the domain name.
But it's virtually
empty right now.
And so if I go to a web browser
and I enter that
name-- oh, and I did set
the CNAME in the
DNS system as well.
So when you enter
cloud-and-clear.com, it's
being redirected automatically
to Google Cloud Storage.
But the problem is there's
nothing in that directory.
And one more thing.
If I show you the way that you
GET and SET the metadata for
website configuration can be
done through a special command
in gsutil called getwebcfg.
So if I enter that command,
cloud-and-clear.com, here's
the configuration I've
set on this bucket.
So by default, I want the
MainPageSuffix to be
index.html.
So if there's an object
index.html, I want that served
up any time someone does
a GET on the bucket.
And if you can't find the
requested object underneath
that bucket, I want Google Cloud
Storage to serve up the
contents of 404.html.
Now, the problem is neither
of those objects have been
uploaded to this bucket.
And so when I access the bucket
right now, I've got the
configuration set that says by
default if you don't specify a
particular object, serve
up index.html.
There is no index.html.
There's no such key
in that bucket.
And so I'm getting
an error message.
So what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to upload
index.html.
And it should make my
problem go away.
Now, the way I'm going to upload
it is I have something
called upload_home,
I call it, which
uploads really two files.
Since I showed you the
configuration is enabling both
the MainPageSuffix and the
NotFoundPage, I'm going to
upload both in one shot.
So this script is copying
home.html and 404.html, home
to index, and 404 to 404.
And then it sets the ACLs
on both to public read.
So if I run upload_home, it's
kind of my home environment.
It's setting both index.html
and 404.
So now, if I refresh,
I get the contents.
I should've shown you what the
contents of that file was.
So index.html is a very simple
page with a header and one
link to a sub-domain, /pool.
So as you see, it's now
serving that up.
And I didn't have to say,
cloud-and-clear/index.html.
I could have done that.
But I didn't need to because
it picked up the default
setting here.
If I instead ask for something
that doesn't
exist, I get a 404 page.
That's my 404 page, actually.
That's not Google's.
And if I show you the 404,
it looks like this.
I copied this from Google's
Broken Robot page that some of
you have seen before.
But I actually crafted
this myself,
uploaded it into 404.html.
And that's what I'm getting when
I request something that
doesn't exist, like foo.
So let's go back to the top.
And I have this link on the
index.html page to Pool Demo.
And if I hover over that,
hopefully you can see at the
bottom of the window-- let me
raise it a little bit, just in
case it's cutting off.
If I hover on that, you see at
the bottom of the window it's
showing you the link
underneath there is
cloud-and-clear.com/pool.
Now, I didn't upload Pool.
So if I do that, I'm getting my
error page that I already
showed you.
So what I'd like to do now
is upload Pool, which is
essentially a static website.
So I've got a script
called upload_pool.
And all that does is it uses
gsutil to copy, "-r" means
recursively, from the
current directory to
cloud-and-clear.com/pool.
So it's creating a subdirectory
with the
recursive contents of this
website that you'll see what
it does in a minute.
And then it sets the ACL again
to public read, because I want
everybody in the world to
be able to access this.
So I'm going to run
upload/pool.
And it's a significant-sized
website.
But the interesting thing
about this website, it's
completely static on
the server side.
There's no server-side logic.
But you see it's quite dynamic
in terms of their client.
So now that I've set this,
I should be able to
click on Pool Demo.
And I probably need to
refresh the page.
The previous result
was cached.
And that's what I get.
And I'll show you there's
more to that.
But let me go back to the
main URL and show
that that just works.
Now, I can either click on that
link and get to the Pool
thing or I can specify
Pool explicitly
myself and get to it.
Now, what's happening is that
Pool is a subdir, it's a
subdirectory underneath the
cloud-and-clear.com bucket.
And in that subdir is
an index.html file.
If that didn't exist, then when
I went to the /pool URL,
I would be getting
the 404 NotFound.
And I can just show you that
very quickly by displaying the
contents of cloud-and-clear.
com/pool/index.html.
And there it is.
So what this site is actually
doing is downloading an app
that's got some pretty
JavaScript with audio and
visual stuff to it.
I can click the Spacebar, and
I approach the pool ball.
And then I can hold
down the Spacebar.
And it actually has audio files
attached to it, so it
sort of simulates the sound
effects of the pool.
If I click on Space, it brings
me to the cue ball.
I can rearrange the table
to my liking.
I'm not a very good pool
player, so I won't
do this very well.
But then I can do the same
thing, hold down the Spacebar
and blast away.
And it would be nice if I
actually got a ball into a
pocket here, because it makes
it makes a cool sound.
But I'm probably not a good
enough pool player to do that.
I'll give it one more try,
and then we'll move on.
People are probably
laughing at--
pool players right now are
laughing at me, I'm sure.
Yay!
OK.
Anyway, you're welcome
to try that.
And one cute thing about
these slides--
let me go back to the start
presentation thing.
I'm sorry, it keeps bringing
me back to the beginning.
But one cute thing about
this slide is
that this is clickable.
This image on the slide
is clickable.
So if you're watching at home,
walking through this
presentation right now, you can
click on the image of the
pool table.
And it should take you
right to the demo.
And you can try it
out for yourself.
It's kind of fun.
So that was it.
Let's just kind of recap what we
did there, because we did a
lot of things.
We set up CNAME redirection so
that this cloud-and-clear.com
imaginary domain name property
that I created was serving
resources directly from Google
Cloud Storage with the names I
like instead of something
that was forced on me.
Then I configured the website
settings for the bucket that I
created, modeling
the domain name.
And then I uploaded content.
And I'm now able to serve
websites directly from that
bucket as well as subdirectories
like that /pool
path from that bucket.
So I effectively have a little
website distribution system
here that's pretty much
infinitely scalable and high
performance and global, and
all that good stuff.
A quick list of resources
here for people who
want to read more.
There's a link here
for the console.
The Developers Console is the
entry point for all of our
cloud products.
So if you want to get access
to Cloud Storage as well as
anything else--
App Engine, Compute Engine, all
our different products--
that's kind of the entry point
as well as where you
administer and set
up your projects.
There's a Product Description
site.
And our documentation
is quite good.
So I'd recommend that third
link there if you want to
learn more specifically
about Cloud Storage.
The feature I've covered today
is on this link here, Website
Configuration.
And lastly, you see a link to
the demo that you can use
again to try yourself.
That's pretty much it, right
on the half-hour.
So what I wanted to do
next is just to open
things up to your questions.
Either we can take questions
from the moderated list or the
Chat window.
Or ideally, maybe we'll first
give people a crack who are in
the Hangout right now.
So let me undo the screensharing
here.
And by the way, we're open and
actually quite interested in
not just questions, but if you
have feedback, if something's
not working right for you, you
think we should be doing
something differently,
please let us know.
We're interested in that stuff
quite a bit as well.
So yeah, why don't I open it
up to the Hangout first.
And don't all jump
at once, please.
Anything from the Hangout?
Going once.
OK.
If you guys get interested
later, just jump right in at
any time, please.
I'm going to switch to
the Moderator queue.
The top rated one, I think,
is a question about--
well, no.
Actually it's fair. "Is there
a way to back up Google Docs
to Google Storage directly?"
There's no direct way in the
sense of having a button to
press kind of thing.
The way to do this would
probably be to write an
application to do it.
We had a request on the
discussion group for Cloud
Storage recently.
That was in the space of how
to move data from a Google
Drive spreadsheet into
Google Cloud Storage.
And in answering that
question I learned
about some Apps Script.
If you're familiar with that
capability, it's a way to
write JavaScript-like code that
manipulates Google Docs content.
So there's a way to use
Apps Script to move
data between the two.
But it still boils down to
writing an app to do that.
There's no direct pass-through
type capability
that I'm aware of.
Let's keep going.
"Can there be a multistep
verification process enforced
on Google Storage before
allowing files
on GCS to be removed?
Ville, want to take
a crack at that?
You can say no.
VILLE AIKAS: Sorry.
I just had to get
unmuted there.
So yeah, right now there
is no way to do this.
But we're always looking at
ways of improving that.
I assume it would be some
kind of a two-factor
authentication.
Maybe the person is not here.
But I assume that's
what they mean.
So we have to go ahead and see
how much interest there is.
And hopefully in the
future, we can
investigate adding that option.
But right now, there's not.
MARC COHEN: Right.
And there's a group that people
can join if you're
interested in getting more
detail on what you envision
this to look like.
I guess the other thing you
could do is just add to this.
Whoever posted this--
Brandon from Sacramento--
if you'd care to just add to
this question with a little
bit more information about how
you saw this working, that
would help us figure out how it
might look, how it might be
implemented.
"What are some tools you would
recommend non-developers use
to interact with GCS?"
So the first comment I would
make is that Google Cloud
Storage is primarily focusing
on application developers.
So that's really the
target audience
for the product initially.
But there are some ways to
interact with it without
having to write code,
for example.
And the two tools that I would
mention are one is the one
I've already shown you guys
with the gsutil command.
And the other one would be that
there's a web user interface.
The name of the tool is the
Google Cloud Storage Manager.
And you can find it in the
documentation page
I pointed you to.
So that gives you the ability
to do things like drag and
drop files from your desktop
to Cloud Storage, and list
buckets and objects,
and so on.
Let's see.
Comment?
OK.
"How experimental is logging?
What are some best practices.
And could you recommend some
third-party services?"
I think logging is pretty well
established at this point.
I presume Dan is referring
to our logging feature.
And so just to explain for
anybody who's not aware of it,
we have a feature called Access
Logs, which give you
the ability to get information
about who's--
kind of low-level tracking
information about every access
to your buckets and
your objects.
And that information gets
posted periodically to a
separate bucket that
you define.
And it gives you fine-grain
ability to monitor what the
activity is on your resources.
I'm not sure about the
experimental status, where
that is and when that's supposed
to be changing.
Do you know anything
about that, Ville?
VILLE AIKAS: I'm sorry.
I was actually chatting with
Hal there about their logs.
I was spacing for a second.
Can you just read
the question?
MARC COHEN: How experimental
is logging?
VILLE AIKAS: It should be
pretty well established.
We are always taking
feature requests.
But we feel like it's pretty
well in there.
Once again, it would be nice
to know if there are some
particular issues or feature
enhancements that people are
looking for.
MARC COHEN: Right.
And then, I don't have any
particular recommendations for
third-party services in
the logging space.
But as Ville mentioned, if you
would care to share a little
bit more information about what
you're trying to do with
the logging feature, we
can definitely try to
explain that better.
"How to start Cloud Storage
use in Google App Engine."
So there is actually an API in
App Engine, integrated right
into App Engine for
interacting with
Google Cloud Storage.
And I think if you search on
Google Cloud Storage App
Engine, you'll very likely
find it in one of the
top-returned hits.
That's probably the best way to
interact with Google Cloud
Storage that's supported in
both Java and Python.
You may find cases where you
need to do something that is
outside of the scope of what's
supported by that API.
And there are ways to work
around the API or circumvent
it and go directly to
programming interface we have
supported for Cloud Storage.
Without knowing more about what
you're trying to do, the
best way to start would be to
look at the published API
that's built right into App
Engine and see if that does
what you need.
The next one is a Google
Drive question.
Someone's asking when there
will be a Linux version of
Google Drive.
And as I mentioned earlier,
that's outside the
scope of this talk.
So unfortunately for Adita,
I'm going to have
to skip that one.
Sorry.
"Is CNAME redirection with
HTTPS on the roadmap?"
That's a pretty relevant
question to what I've been
talking about, and I don't
know the answer to that.
In general, we don't reveal
future plans.
We're not allowed to talk about
what we're going to do
down the road.
But we've heard of
this before.
We're aware that this is an
important capability.
So we're taking it into
consideration
for our future planning.
Is there anything else you want
to say on that, Ville?
VILLE AIKAS: Nope.
That's pretty much.
MARC COHEN: So it's
a good point.
And we agree.
It seems like a very useful
thing to be able to do.
"Do Google Cloud Storage domain
name CNAMES need to be
associated with a Google
App account?"
MARC COHEN: I think the
answer to that is no.
I'm not sure, I guess, what Adam
means exactly by a Google
App account, whether you mean
like a Google App for Domains
type account or just a Gmail
account, a Google account.
I guess I'm going to assume it's
a Google account proper,
like a Gmail ID or something
like that.
The CNAME capability is
independent of the Gmail or
the Google IDs.
Basically, You'll create
a domain name.
And you'll have to prove
ownership of that.
I'm trying to think if
you need a Google
account in order to--
you might need a Google account
in order to actually
do the verification steps.
Because the way that
works is you go to
Google Webmaster Tools.
And you go through an
interactive wizard on that web
page that steps you through the
different ways to verify
your domain.
So that might be one
place where you
need a Google account.
Like some of these other
questions, if there's
something you're trying to do
that makes this a problem, let
us know and we'll try to see
if there's a workaround.
Let's see.
Any questions on the Hangout
before I keep going here?
And I see lots of activity
in the Chat window.
I won't try to recap that.
But thanks, Ville, for helping
out over there.
"Are there any plans to allow
any edge-cached copies of GCS
objects to be cleared
programmatically, overriding
the original cache
control header?"
Not that I'm aware of.
I think your only option
at the moment is to use
conservative values in terms of
the life of the object and
wait for it to time out.
I guess I'm curious to know
whether there's a problem
there or what the application
need is that
would motivate that.
But as of now, the
edge caching--
AUDIENCE: That was
my question.
And the problem is when
people make mistakes.
So if you have some content
that's supposed to be served
up with a long lifetime, and you
like the edge caching and
everything, but then you
realize, oops, that was wrong,
and you're not using strongly
named objects or something,
then it would be nice.
It's not a must-have feature.
We can make do without it.
But it would be nice to be able
to say, actually, guys,
we didn't mean that.
Can you clear the edge cache
so we can serve up the new
thing under that name that we
meant in the first place?
VILLE AIKAS: Right.
Right.
So yeah, so right now it's
a little difficult.
With the caching obviously,
especially when it's just
really caching over
the internet,
it's very, very difficult.
We could certainly go
ahead and maybe do a
little bit on our end.
But even then, you would
have any intermediary
caches along the way.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, understood.
I mean, even if it were best
effort, it would still be a
useful feature for us.
VILLE AIKAS: Yep.
Yep, yep, yep.
AUDIENCE: But I do understand
that it's hard.
MARC COHEN: Is there a way to
modify the cache by changing
the lifetime to a very small
number, the header that
dictates how long the cache
element should be retained?
AUDIENCE: Once you've set it to
a big number and it's been
cached, the problem is that that
cache then knows its age.
It doesn't need to check back
with the actual economical
storage of the object.
MARC COHEN: That make sense.
VILLE AIKAS: It's the same
problem as with the DNS--
oops!
MARC COHEN: Right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And we've made that
mistake, too.
MARC COHEN: I didn't
mention that.
That's actually a good point.
I meant to point that out.
One of the biggest gotchas
that people run into--
I was talking through the CNAME
redirection business
early on in the tech talk
portion of this Hangout.
And I wanted to mention that
when you're doing that, be
liberal about how much time you
wait for things to change,
for the world to reconfigure.
What will happen
is typically--
especially, for example, setting
up the CNAME record in
DNS, you'll go to your name
registrar and make that change
administratively, administrative
that text
record, for example, or
the CNAME record.
And then you'll go try it,
and it won't work.
And it's just because of
the nature of DNS.
It takes a while for things
to propagate.
So use liberal test intervals
when you're doing that stuff.
OK.
Let's see what else
we have here.
Any other questions
from the Hangout?
AUDIENCE: I joined
the Hangout late.
I was watching the video.
So you might have said
this already.
But I think you handled a
question from the Moderator
earlier about an extra step of
verification when you're
deleting objects
through the web
interface for cloud storage.
And I think what the person
was getting at was just an
"Are you sure?
Yes or no," if you click the
Delete button on the web
interface rather than anything
to do with two-step
verification, which is what I
think you might have thought.
MARC COHEN: OK.
Yeah.
Thank you for correcting that.
I think you're right.
AUDIENCE: Because also I would
like that feature.
It sounds like a really
small thing.
But the web interface is
really convenient.
But at the moment, I sometimes
daren't use it because I'm
worried about hitting
that button with no
"Are you sure?" step.
VILLE AIKAS: Ah, OK, OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm even thinking of
writing a Chrome extension
just to give me an "Are
you Sure?" button.
MARC COHEN: Yeah.
Yeah.
And I think that as the scope
of deletion increases, that
becomes even more critical.
And then you can take that idea
even further and imagine
a trash-can type model, where
the stuff that you delete
doesn't actually get deleted.
It goes somewhere else outside
of your normal view.
And then later on, if you decide
you made a mistake, you
can restore it.
I think those are
all good ideas.
And I personally would love
to see more of that.
So like I said earlier, I can't
give any specifics.
But that's a great point.
And thank you for clarifying
that question.
I think it was misinterpreted.
VILLE AIKAS: And just to extend
a little bit, we did
talk about the I/O, that they're
going have versioning
coming very, very soon.
So you can basically go instead
of buckets, go and
have versions.
So we keep copies for you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That sounds useful.
VILLE AIKAS: So if you're
interested in being a
participant when it becomes
available, just go and send a
note to the gs-team@google.com,
and we can
go ahead and put you on
to it when it becomes
available to show.
MARC COHEN: Thanks, Ville.
Next question is "has anyone
worked on porting the OAuth 2
Boto plug-in to Boto itself?
And how would you pass in the
access token during runtime in
non-Google App Engine projects,
for example, a
vanilla Django project?"
MARC COHEN: So the second part
of the question, how would you
pass the access token
during runtime?
There are ways to get--
I assume this is a Python
programmer, because I see the
references to Boto.
There are ways to get access to
the inner OAuth goodies--
AUDIENCE: OAuth 2.
MARC COHEN: Sorry?
I thought maybe we got lucky
again and had the questioner
in the Hangout.
So there are ways to get access
to the refresh token
and the access token and extract
it from the underlying
library wrappers that make the
OAuth 2 stuff easier to use,
both in Boto and also
using the Google
Python Client Library.
As far as porting the OAuth 2
Boto plug-in to Boto itself,
what that's about in case
anybody's wondering what
that's talking about is the
tool that I showed you
earlier, gsutil, is a Python
application that we've
open-sourced.
And it's layered on top of
Boto, which is a popular
third-party, also open-source
Python programming library.
The purpose of Boto is to make
it easy to develop cloud
computing apps using Python.
And it supports Amazon stuff
as well as Google Cloud
Storage and a few
other things.
And gsutil, the tool I was
using earlier, uses Boto.
In order to make it work with
Google Cloud Storage, we did
some work in Boto-- and other
people did, as well-- to make
Boto understand how
to interact with
Google Cloud Storage.
One of the things that we had
to sort of teach Boto how to
do was to get OAuth
2 credentials.
And that part of the puzzle
was done in the
gsutil command itself.
It's not baked into the
lower-level Boto library.
And the person's asking, has
any work been done to move
that functionality
down into Boto?
And it's been something
we've thought about.
And also it makes sense to us.
But we haven't actually
worked on that.
And Boto and gsutil both being
open-source projects, we would
totally be happy to invite and
review any work that anybody
wanted to do in that space if
you are enthusiastic about
helping in that area.
It doesn't mean we won't do it
or somebody else won't do it.
It's just we haven't gotten
to it up to this point.
Let's see.
Down to two more
questions here.
"Integration with PageSpeed,
can't get it to work."
So PageSpeed is a Google service
that speeds up--
I guess I don't know
too much about it.
But my understanding is it
analyzes your website content
and helps you optimize the
download speed by doing things
like minimizing JavaScript
syntax and other techniques.
Maybe somebody on the
Hangout knows more.
Feel free to jump
in if you do.
I assume this person's--
go ahead.
It sounded like we had
a comment there.
No?
Sorry if I'm interrupting
anybody.
I think there's a bit of
delay on this line.
I assume the questioner is
saying specifically PageSpeed
with respect to the website
configuration feature I've
been talking about.
So I'd like to know more about
what didn't work for you.
But I will reach out to the
questioner after the call and
try to find out about that
because it sounds like an
interesting area that I
haven't tried myself.
"Has client software of Windows
been launched?"
JEFF SILVERMAN: I've got
an answer for that one.
MARC COHEN: OK.
Let me get you on camera here.
JEFF SILVERMAN: Hi.
I'm Jeff Silverman.
I'm a development support
specialist.
And I got the gsutil utility
working quite nicely under
Windows and Cygwin.
MARC COHEN: Thanks, Jeff.
So that's another
option you have.
gsutil, the tool I was using
earlier, can be run
on Windows as well.
In fact, it can be run
without Cygwin.
But I think it's a little
bit easier--
JEFF SILVERMAN: It works a
lot better with Cygwin.
MARC COHEN: With Cygwin.
That's the end of the
question list.
I'm just checking to see if a
couple more might have popped
up in the meantime.
"Any alternatives to Google
Storage Manager?"
So that's the web
user interface.
And there are commercial
products that are available
and support Google
Cloud Storage.
So there are few third-party
alternatives out there.
And if you Google Cloud Storage,
Google Cloud Storage,
web UI, something along those
lines, you should be able to
find a few.
But there's no alternative
that's officially supported as
of now by Google.
And let's see.
I think that pretty much covers
the Moderator questions.
So we're coming up towards
the end of the hour.
We have about five
minutes left.
I'll just open it up one
more time for any
questions in the Hangout.
And then I think we'll
close up shop here.
Any other questions live?
OK.
Well, thank you guys all
for joining us today.
Hope you got something
out of it.
And we'll try to do more
these in the future.
VILLE AIKAS: Thanks, guys.
MARC COHEN: Thank you.